welcome to fantasy video channel Island
I didn't stick that landing did I quit
plus if your fantasy is to watch me
review this movie yet I question your
fantasies but you're here so let's do it
let's talk about a movie
[Music]
Fantasy Island longhouses Fantasy Island
that is Fantasy Island is a movie
adaptation of the old TV show in the 70s
started Ricardo Montalban he played mr.
Roarke and people go to the island and
they could live out a fantasy and
there's a lesson to be learned there's
also a remake of the show in the 90s
starring Malcom McDowel as mr. Roarke
one is we have a remake now by Blum
House and Michael Pena is mr. Roarke
which the marketing in this movie you're
like odds like a horror movie it's
fantasy island but a slasher flick I'd I
guess it does lend itself to that okay
I'm curious to have my curiosity now
saying it had my attention but curiosity
and that's the gist a bunch of people
come to this island they're gonna live
out their fantasies and then it just
starts you know it turns into a plumb
house picture which first of all Michael
Pena plays mr. Roarke in this movie he
wouldn't have been my first call I love
Michael Pena I really do I'm a fan of a
guy best I can describe it it's like mr.
Roark for me always felt like a
character from lost or rather characters
from lost reminded me of mr. Roark where
there's something supernatural going on
here something supernatural about that
person I don't even know what they are a
person I don't know it makes me a little
uneasy but I respect the authority but
they illustrate that through their vibe
not the movie describing the power
behind the island you get it because
Ricardo Montalban with his commanding
presence is commanding angelic presence
which let's be honest that's just him
not even know he's being filmed
that's just Ricardo Montalban Horace
Malcom McDowel devilish quality he
brought to mr. Rourke he'd show up like
let him come to Fantasy Island you're
like okay Satan I are you the devil
himself do I need to clutch my soul
again now completely convinced Malcom
McDowel does not have a briefcase full
of souls in his closet the guy just
gives off that vibe Michael Pena's vibe
is hey let's go grab a beer does Michael
Pena just kind of feels like a dude a
colleague a co-worker dude I could have
a beer with it actually does work for
what they're going for in the movie by
the end just didn't see mr. Roark hair
and I liked half this movie say that
like not the capacity of first half of
the movie versus second half of the
movie the kind of the capacity of the
Warcraft movie in Warcraft everything
with the orcs was great I loved it for
the Horde you know what I'm spitting now
everything with the human beings just
kind of bored me so in that I like half
of
Warcraft movie kind of intermittently
woven into itself that's the way it is
with Fantasy Island when it was being
Fantasy Island and the fantasies are
playing out and people are starting to
learn their lessons of Oh be careful
what you wish for maybe you shouldn't
try to change the past maybe your past
is there for you to own it when the
lessons are going down like a Fantasy
Island movie I was like okay I'm
actually enjoying this there is one
fantasy that is most definitely from
beginning to end the Blum House element
it's the slasher flick element the girl
who wants to torture her highschool
bully I was kind of impressed that they
were all making a legit attempt at
making a Fantasy Island movie until it
became an overblown very convoluted
slasher flick and then I got bored it's
as simple as that and it really does
play out like I know what you did last
summer it's like I know what you did on
the island last summer wow this is so
from the 90s Malcolm McDowell definitely
could have played mr. Rourke and I do
mean the movie is overblown it's drawn
out at a point you're like this movie is
way too long and it's not just run time
it's time management so much happens in
the last act of this movie in the name
of keeping you guessing that it detracts
from any of the lessons that might have
been learned in the first act of the
movie and it makes the movie feel about
a half an hour longer than it probably
is it's just convoluted so in the end
fantasy island kind of started out like
Fantasy Island and then turned into I
know what you did on the island last
summer so it's like I started out
wanting to give them credit for trying
to make a fantasy island movie I just
hate him even more for just burning it
to the ground not really gonna remember
it in t-minus one day
yep already forgot you know what I
realized while watching this if Blum
house made a night trap movie I would
not hate it I'm just saying
Michael Rooker's in this movie and he
basically plays Eddie from night trap
and I was like holy [ __ ] blunt house
night trap I wouldn't hate it that'd be
my fantasy on fantasy island right there
it's like good I'd like my night trap
movie please you can keep the orgies in
the blow I just priorities I question
your fantasies ISO Fantasy Island have
you seen it what did you think about it
did you see the original with Ricardo
Montalban did you see the 90s remake
with Malcolm McDowell are you going to
see this whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]